one of the most popular sort of punching
bags
for conservatives right now is the state
of california they love to say
california is a liberal hellhole
california is what happens when the
left-wing policies of democrats
run rampant but the truth is that that's
bogus and a few weeks ago i did a story
called
so-called failed state of california
sets
economic growth record and in that story
i went through the economic data and it
turns out california is actually doing
really well economic growth is some of
the highest in the us in california
the economic surplus in california the
budget surplus is at a record level
so those claims about california
throughout the pandemic have been false
another talking point is people are
fleeing california everybody's leaving
california
it's going to be left empty the
cupboards will be bare of people
as trump likes to say we now have a new
study about that
and it is also just a lie republicans
want to paint california as a place
that people are just desperate to get
out of they'll go anywhere they'll
just get me out of california and it
never passed
the sniff test because if people really
were getting out
their magical perfect rational market
would lead to a significant drop in the
cost of living in california
basic supply and demand rents would go
down
property values would go down that's not
happening but
putting the sniff test aside there's a
new study from the university of
california system
which found that the number of people
moving out of california to other states
is up slightly compared to 2012 but it's
at very similar numbers to what we saw
throughout the mid and late 2000s there
are some people moving out as people
move out move out of any state
but at historically sort of normal
levels meanwhile there are still young
people
moving into california at relatively
high rates they're also going other
places some of them are going to texas
some of them are going to colorado
you do see some older folks moving out
of california
but it's really no big deal the
percentage of californians who plan to
leave the state
when you ask them has remained basically
the same over the last two years
23 of california california voters say i
am seriously considering leaving the
state
that was 24 2 years ago basically the
same
that sounds huge and obviously if a
quarter of california left
california it would be a cataclysm
economically
but remember that most people who say
they're considering leaving don't i mean
i've been considering moving to miami
for five years and then i realize
i don't really know anybody there i'd be
far from my family
i'm gonna stay put at least for now but
like if you ask me at many points
i i would consider leaving and going to
florida sure yeah
that's something i've considered not
really going to do it and that's for
most people
one interesting thing is that there's a
big partisan gap though on that question
if you ask democrats 21 say i'm
considering leaving california
if you ask republicans 30 percent say
i'm considering leaving california
no surprise politically it's very and
vogue right now to say
you're thinking of leaving california
any guys
i'll do it don't make me because i'm
just one day from
renting a u-haul and getting out of here
most people don't do it
and it's important to remember that if
people did leave california in large
numbers the heroic
perfect market that the republicans love
to harp on
would lead to lower prices that's what
republicans claim is the problem in
california they say prices are too high
a real estate costs too much rent is too
damn high
that's caused by demand there's a reason
it's more expensive to live in san
francisco than it is to live in
you know tulsa oklahoma no offense to
oklahoma
education is better in california
there are higher salaries in california
than in oklahoma there's more access to
culture
there's more access to airports with
direct flights to the rest of the world
there's a higher standard of healthcare
there's better infrastructure it
demand drives prices up doesn't mean
people in oklahoma are bad people
it's just the market that these right
wingers point to
that's why it's expensive to be in
california but
right wingers just feel like everybody's
leaving california
so do we pay attention to fats or do we
pay attention to feelings i forget how
that statement goes
over time people may leave california
who knows but it's just not happening
right now
to any significant degree california's
not failing economically
and people are not fleeing california
that's the truth
it may change in the future but it's not
happening right now